[Music]
1905 Albert Einstein's mother thought he
was a junior his sister thought he's a
genius his father thought he's a genius
but he was stuck in the Patent Office in
Bern Switzerland and nobody else
Ludington genius at all
he had mouthed off to his professors his
university he didn't get any good job
his Department of theoretical physics
was the top drawer of his desk idiot
slam it closed but then and he had tried
all sorts of things he was about 25 26
he had tried lots of ideas on him stuck
at the Patent Office nothing had really
come together and then suddenly in the
spring of 1905 it was like a storm burst
in fed he poured out one paper after
another about four of them were worthy
of the Nobel Prize and the final two
were special relativity and e equals MC
squared Einstein once said he wasn't
smarter than other people but he said I
have the persistence of a mule and he
was really honest about it when he was a
little kid in to make card capsules he'd
make layer after layer after layer of
card castles and if they blew down well
he takes a deep breath and build it up
again so he knew he won't understand how
the universe worked
it always thought the universe was like
a series of books waiting on a shelf
that if we were really lucky we could
take them down and look inside and
there'd be all the truth of the universe
inside there it might be the Sermon on
the Mount for Matthew it might be what
he later discovered things like equals
mc-squared
and most of the time we couldn't look in
those books but occasionally we could
and that's what drove him all through
his early 20s he was happily married at
the beginning to a really hot young
Serbian physics student but the only
woman in his class at the Polytechnic in
Zurich and they had great dreams of
maybe becoming professors together but
reality got in the way he was stuck with
a patent office and until 1905 when he
was 25 26 he couldn't get any fresh
ideas and he in his wife's they began to
slowly drift apart
she had it they didn't have money for
child care she was stuck at home taking
care of the kids she couldn't really
participate in his work in 1905 he did
have this epiphany or series of
epiphanies he had great great
achievements and he thought he was home
clear but nothing happened the great
professors in Germany one or two of them
monitor his work but he couldn't get a
job he applied at one point to teach in
high school in Switzerland and he
submitted as a justification for
teaching science in high school the
theory of relativity equals mc-squared
and a few other things like that he was
rejected this was Switzerland he hadn't
done the proper forms they weren't
properly typed and he stayed in the
Patent Office some people will take
offence very easily they get a little
you know negative look and they think oh
people don't like me I'm saying was not
like that and he had good reason to to
think that people didn't like him in
1920 in Germany the Opera House in
Berlin was taken over by an anti
Einstein rally they were slashed because
in the front well this wasn't aryan
science this was jewish science it had
to be wrong and then horribly in 1933
his books were burned on the streets in
germany and they weren't just burned by
uneducated mobs from the middle of
nowhere the greatest university the
world had known was Christian get in
Germany at the time and the students
there the students were so caught up in
what was happening that they drag on
Stein's books and books of other people
and they burned him in huge paths and
huge piles right in the centre in Berlin
and Girton gaya and in other places
luckily by then Einstein was out of the
country some of the major newspapers and
magazines were you know charging him
with they said they had to kill him it's
a variation they didn't just say lock
him up they said the next stage you
start with one stage you go to the next
because he was famous he managed to get
to America he he lived safely in a in
Princeton New Jersey after that but he
was also a nobleman and he realized he
had to save a lot of people so he used a
huge amount of his income and other
funds that he raised to get people who
are danger of death out of harm's way
into the safety of America and that's
one of the some lessons for us today so
after the first world war where vast
numbers of people had died machine gun
for no purpose in you know in in Western
Europe and of course even huge battles
also in Eastern Europe great number of
people thought what to be worth it what
could be worth sending millions of young
men rushing into machine guns which are
firing her way and killing them so
Einstein thought no war is going to be
worth it well in the late 1930s with the
rights of
he changed his mind he thought this is
different this could actually destroy
all civilization so he didn't like it
but he said yeah we have to defend
ourselves we have to stop this this
terrible thing he himself was not
allowed to work on the atomic bomb the
FBI thought he was a security risk in
fact he wasn't a security risk
but the FBI as usual was being very very
cautious also a month of the atomic bomb
although it intellectually owes the
ideas John Stein a lot of it was
practical engineering and he wasn't an
engineer he was good with his hands and
building things but he wasn't a
practical engineer so he actually wasn't
involved in the building of the bomb
then in 1945 about a day after it was
dropped on Hiroshima when the news
finally reached America he was on
holiday in eastern Long Island he liked
boating
his secretary Helen do Kosh will come up
she said professor this is terrible news
she told him what had happened and he
woke up and he said to her if I had
known I wouldn't have lifted a finger
[Music]